and some business news now tesla ceo
elon musk is calling for a 10 reduction
in staff at the electric car maker
according to an email sent on thursday
and seen by reuters news agency musk
also called for a pause on all hiring
worldwide saying he has a quote super
bad feeling about the economy tesla
employs nearly 100 000 people according
to a u.s government filing last year
musk now joins a growing number of
business leaders warning about the risk
of a recession
and we have our senior business editor
ben fazoulen here in the studio to break
this down for us welcome ben
so musk has this super bad feeling about
the economy tell us more why is he
feeling so bad it's very trumpian
sounding isn't it um it's nothing new to
me i mean
interest rates were about to start
increasing and did start increasing in
the us before the pandemic hit and when
the pandemic hit it was clear okay
interest rates are going to stay low but
sure as soon as the pandemic starts
easing those interest rates are going to
go back up and that's what they've been
doing uh so you hear all about inflation
now about a possible recession and
you've got the ukraine war which is
really thrown a spanner into the works
as far as the economy the global economy
goes so a lot of people are worried
about that musk's comments did send u.s
stock futures
falling just before trading today on
wall street
it's also adding to these worries that
uh an aggressive policy tightening by
the fed could tip the economy into
recession basically so he's basically
putting on the brakes after years and
years of
constant expansion yeah it was like no
limits this guy wants to go to mars you
know and colonize the planet um he built
this huge uh factory battery factory uh
just near berlin and they're already
talking about expanding that open a
factory in texas they're extending
shanghai
then china's lockdown came and that
caused a lot of problems it's factory
that was closed for three weeks the
second quarter is looking bad as far as
sales go
and its share price has been in trouble
since april uh in pre-market trading the
share has fallen by three and a half
percent
musk has really always been seen as a
visionary hasn't he um and yet you know
with all of this caution he's he's
sounding a little old-school now yeah
very old school um i mean how he runs a
business even uh this this um email he
sent out to workers this week saying
that they've got to be in in the office
40 hours a week minimum 40 hours
none of this home office stuff uh
you know he he wants the decision makers
and sure i can understand that to be in
the one place where they can
spontaneously exchange ideas and that
sort of thing and maybe it's just all
those years he spent doing late nights
sleeping on a mattress in his office
that has really you know formed a bond
between him and his workplace so how are
the workers reacting to this well um i
mean
i can understand
if he doesn't want people to work
for a company in their own
four walls next to a coffee machine all
day with a cat jumping around and a baby
and whatever else
but um
yeah i mean that's the harsh reality of
it and he's cutting ten percent of the
workforce so those who don't like it can
go he's he's offered them that um but as
far as tesla goes the brand remains
solid
um it's a leader in in the technology
that it does it's increasing market
share it is still talking about
expanding
um
as far as its other factories go
and uh it's going to be very interesting
to see what the competition does in asia
because uh there many countries are
coming up with their own electric
vehicles and they're putting on the
pressure we shall see ben fizzling
thanks so much